five years ago i made a video for a
channel called computer file about why
electronic voting is a bad idea
and i still get emails occasionally
asking things
must have changed by now right there's
this new idea and maybe it'll help
surely electronic voting is is just
around the corner
no no it's it's really not
here is why electronic voting is still a
bad idea
[Music]
elections have some very unusual
requirements there are two key features
that are almost
opposed to each other anonymity and
trust
so first your vote should be completely
anonymous there should be no way
that anyone can find out who you voted
for even after everything's been counted
that way no one can bribe you or
threaten you to vote a particular way
in the uk if you mark your ballot in a
way that could potentially identify you
so if you
sign it for example then that ballot is
not counted
this is why election officials are
worried about people taking selfies with
their ballots
because you should not be able to prove
how you voted afterwards
otherwise you can have a tax like ten
dollars off for blue voters or
entry to this party only for yellow
voters or vote red or you'll regret it
votes have to be anonymous the second
requirement
is absolute transparent trust the system
needs to make sure that your vote is
securely and accurately counted sure
but it also needs to be obvious to
everyone no matter their technical
knowledge
that the system can be trusted
so if you're using paper you place your
ballot in a sealed box
that doesn't get unsealed until everyone
with a stake in the election
has someone representing them in the
room there should always be people from
more than one side guarding it or at the
very least
witnessing that there's a tamper-proof
seal being used for transport
voters need to be able to trust their
vote will be countered even though
they'll never see it again
and it can't be traced back to them and
at no point is a single person put in a
position of trust
people can be corrupt or threatened or
incompetent or
all three at the same time now physical
voting is not perfect it can be attacked
it has been attacked
the uk's own paper system doesn't
fulfill both of those requirements
perfectly
it is possible to identify voters from
their ballots if a court orders it
and there are stories about that being
done outside the law too
but the key point is not that paper
voting is perfect it isn't
but attacks against it don't scale well
physical voting is is centuries old and
in that time almost
every conceivable fraud on the system
has been tried
and defenses have been found the more
physical votes you need to change
the more people you need to influence
the more time and money it takes and
the less likely it is that your little
conspiracy will stay secret
in a uk election there are hundreds of
polling stations across the country
with staff made up of scores of
employees and thousands of volunteers
the job of changing a significant number
of votes enough to sway an election
becomes very very difficult people
have attempted it some people have been
convicted a few have probably gotten
away with it on some scale
granny farming is the term that shady
operatives use for going around
all the retirement homes and getting
vulnerable elderly people to to sign a
proxy vote a paper
saying that someone else can vote on
their behalf and yeah on a small scale
that has worked but once you start
scaling up that attack
it becomes extremely difficult and
time-consuming and the chances are
you're going to get found out with
electronic voting
that's not the case so first let's talk
about electronic voting machines that's
where there's a computer at the polling
station so voters still go into a booth
it's just that they are pushing buttons
or tapping things on a touch screen not
writing on paper problem number one
trusting
the software and the hardware in theory
our voting computer could be running
open source software where
anyone can see and check the source code
in practice that doesn't happen it's
probably going to be closed source it's
probably going to be loaded off an
easily compromised usb stick on a
computer that's been sitting
unguarded and sometimes just idly and
inexplicably connected to the internet
for years and those systems only ever
get a full-scale test when an election
actually takes place that in itself
should be enough to stop electronic
voting ever being a thing but
okay let's say that we do magically have
the most stable secure open source
software possible
how does a voter know and trust that
correct software is actually
installed on the machine they're using
maybe we
could use some sort of checksum or some
other system to make sure the voting
software is running correctly but then
you're just moving the problem now you
have to trust that that
checksum hasn't been forged and almost
no voters will
actually understand what that check even
means or why they should trust it
in the united states voting machines are
regularly tested every year
at the voting village at defcon one of
the world's largest hacker conventions
it's not an official thing hackers there
have managed to alter the stored vote
tallies
change the ballots displayed to voters
and in one case have
got a machine to run the video game doom
imagine if instead of a machine there
was just a person in the voting booth
and you had to whisper
your vote to them and they promised oh
yes you can absolutely trust them to
accurately record your vote and
pass it on to the people who are doing
the count no you can't see
how or where they're writing it down you
can't actually
call well then find out where they are
or what they're doing but they
they absolutely promise that's it's
basically what's happening with an
electronic voting machine you just have
something that says
trust me i've counted your vote and i've
absolutely not been compromised
honest problem number two
is votes in transit how do you get the
votes off that machine
to the central accounting place there
are three possible ways one you could
take
all the voting machines to the count you
could seal them all up and transport
them physically
from where where the voting took place
to where the counting takes place
no one does that so you could download
all the results from each machine onto a
usb stick and take that
one bit of sleight of hand and you've
got a completely different set of
results if you're about to propose some
system where the results are check
summed and trusted then
please explain that to the average voter
in a way they can understand and
implicitly trust
okay so maybe we could transmit the
votes electronically
over the internet which is optimistic
man in the middle attacks are more
difficult now but
they're not impossible particularly if
you can't trust the software on either
end
and now you are connecting the voting
machines
directly to the internet deliberately
which brings us to problem number three
the central counting server
right at the end of the process there is
the server
that tallies the votes and gives the
final count
which has all the same problems with
trust and verification as the individual
voting machines
but now only a few people can even see
that computer
that's also true about electronic
counting machines ones that take stacks
of paper ballots
and return totals how do you trust they
aren't quietly changing some votes we
live in a world where volkswagen got
away with specifically
designing their cars to cheat on
emissions tests
for years and that's before we include
user error in one scottish election
trialling electronic voting a result
was corrected after one observer noticed
it didn't make sense and stopped the
announcement at the last minute
turns out that someone forgot to scroll
all the way to the right
to read the columns on an excel
spreadsheet with the results in
and even if you can't compromise the
election you can still
break trust you can still cast doubt on
a voting machine or
the entire accounting system just by
leaving an unknown usb drive in it
taking a picture and posting it online
or just taking a photo of that
to break an electronic election you
don't actually need to break it
you just need to cast enough doubt on
the result it is a lot more difficult to
do that
with paper and physical ballot boxes and
all this
is before we get to the really terrible
idea that people should be able to use
their phone or computer
to vote from home now i am sure
that the device that you personally are
watching this on is malware free and up
to date of course it is
but do you trust that for everyone in
your family for everyone on your street
the exact numbers differ depending on
which security firm's figures you go
with but
it's safe to say that a huge number of
computers are infected with some sort of
malware
huge numbers of phones are on old
vulnerable versions of their operating
systems
and that's just scammers setting up
botnets and minor extortions
imagine the sort of attack that could be
put together by a
small well-funded team backed by a
national government
that sort of attack would scale very
very well find the one hole in the
system and suddenly
it costs roughly the same to change one
vote
as it does to alter millions and your
conspiracy stays very
very small indeed maybe you don't even
have to set foot
in the country whose elections you're
hacking now
there are a couple of regular objections
i get to this first of all
what about estonia yes in 2005
estonia became the first country in the
world to offer internet
voting first in local elections and in
national then in european
in 2019 more than 40 of votes were cast
online there
which is just short of a quarter of a
million people
on the surface the system seems robust
voters can id by their government
provided smart card or the sim card and
their phone
but there are problems an independent
report found gaps in the procedural and
operational security the architecture of
the system is a decade old and
it's now dangerously out of date and
it's open
to cyber attacks by foreign powers
either by exploiting individual phones
or by breaking the trust in the server
that counts the votes
the other common objection is what about
new technologies what about
blockchain look leaving aside
trying to explain blockchain to people
and and asking them to trust that this
weird technology is is
worth using it's basically just a
write-only database it doesn't solve the
problem of trusting the software or
hardware it doesn't change how the
voting machine works the interface
between the voter's intention
and what's actually written to the
database still has to work
if it prints a receipt to the vote then
you can check later when it breaks
anonymity
if it prints a receipt of seemingly
random numbers that you can check later
it breaks trust because hardly anyone
will understand what's actually going on
there
i'm not saying there aren't advantages
to electronic voting yeah there are
accessibility is the main one and that's
really important in low stakes elections
for small groups for the little things
sure go for it
but when the future of nations rests on
the result
electronic voting is still a bad idea
and you should still vote against it
while you can
i'm endorsing dashlane for two reasons
one
they've given me money obviously but two
because i genuinely believe that if you
are techy enough to watch to the end of
this video
you should absolutely be using a
password manager
if you go to dashlane.com tom scott you
can get a free
30-day trial of dashlane premium
password storage generation and autofill
that works across devices
browsers operating systems everything it
syncs
all your data in the cloud without
sending any of those actual passwords to
dashlane themselves if you want to know
how that works
see previous sponsored sections using
long
complicated symbol-filled passwords that
are completely different for every
website and every app
is ideal for security but remembering
them is now impossible
and typing them in is a pain being able
to use a single master password or the
biometrics on your phone
is great you've got one thing to
remember dashlane will also store and
autofill credit card information so you
don't have to retype it every time you
buy something online
you also get a vpn and a gigabyte of
secure storage
so dashlane.com for a 30-day free trial
of dashlane premium which includes
unlimited password storage and sync
and if you like it you can use the code
tom scott for 10 off
you